[Music]
so today we'll be talking about
hazardous models and risk mitigation in
real estate that before you get started
when I like to tape impulse who hears
works on modeling time to event data
before so what I mean hey heads up all
right so some of the kind of questions
that you could have asked oops so for
example what's the half-life of a
start-up in Silicon Valley or when's my
team gonna score another goal so raise
your hand if you have okay now keep your
ends up did you use survival analysis so
okay yeah fair number of people so the
goal is of this talk and hopefully by
the end is to communicate what survival
analysis is and hazard modeling is and
give you all a flavor for how we use it
at open door but first who are we ok
color get a little funky my name is
David and this is my colleague Sigma
Quang
we're both data scientists at open door
and yeah so the talk just to give you an
outline of the talk structure today
we're gonna be talking about a little
bit of real estate 101 or 101 and that's
particularly to motivate the problem of
modeling liquidity and when I say
liquidity today we're gonna be talking
about really just predicting the time on
market for a given home so how long a
listing sits on the market before we
find a buyer for it and we'll we'll show
some like home sale case studies to give
you a flavor for the data and then we're
gonna do a tour of sort of three
different modeling approaches and talk
about the pros and cons of each and it's
sort of roughly mirrors open door
trajectory and sort of the understanding
of this problem and then we'll of course
pause for Q&A at the end so first what
is open door so open doors mission is to
empower everyone with the freedom to
move and so we do this by offering a
service that allows home owners to sell
their homes
with ease and importantly with certainty
and so this is enabled by the fact that
we as a company will actually offer to
buy the properties from the homeowners
and then we take those properties do any
minor repairs or renovations and then
put them back on the market and
hopefully try to find a buyer for them
what this means for us though
is that we as a company open doors a
company bears the risk in reselling the
home the time on market for each home is
going to vary substantially
substantially
we've bought bought and sold thousands
of homes some of in winners but not all
of them so it's important to understand
what are the characteristics of the
homes that really determine their resale
outcomes and finally just as another
motivating point our costs to service
these homes our unit economics are
driven by how long it takes us to find a
buyer for a given home so the longer we
hold a property the more will pay for
financing costs for property taxes for
maintenance to keep the home in a
showing condition so it's very important
for us as a business to be able to
accurately model the duration of home
beyond the market
so just succinctly summarize the problem
we're gonna solve today is how long will
it take us to find a buyer for a home
but first let's take a look at a couple
different sort of examples of the data
that we'll be working with today so
first this is like a historical listing
in one of our markets Phoenix it's a
really beautiful large spacious like 4
bedroom 3 and a half bathroom home it's
like clearly been like either recently
renovated or redone or its brand new and
it's got like a pool with very like
beautiful kind of like a waterfall there
so and it was listed at around $800,000
so raise your hand if you think his home
sold in like one month maybe two months
ok a couple of hands three months more
than two months ok well ok yeah so it
actually sold in more than six months
it's ok it took a long
time so yeah everyone congratulate
yourselves and let's see how are you on
this one so this home is meant to sort
of it'sit's quite a bit smaller let's
say it's still in very good condition
you know it's it's not been recently
upgraded or anything but definitely in
good condition it's got a nice backyard
so if you live in San Francisco
you're probably like that's my dream
home and it was listed at 300 K so how
many people think is sold in a month
also in Phoenix it's not in San
Francisco two months three months okay
so it actually sold in in under one
month so what I'm trying to highlight by
these two examples is that these two
homes have dramatically different resale
outcomes and a large part of that is
driven by their future differences the
bedroom and bathrooms that each of these
homes have that the square footage the
the lot size that they sit on and also
the market conditions so yeah our job is
the business is to be able to be able to
be able to predict that outcome so let's
frame the problem a bit this is sort of
meant to be a snapshot of the data we
have in each of the markets we operate
and we have historical transaction or
sales data for each of these home
listings so for example we have features
about the home number of bedrooms number
of bathrooms but also market conditions
such as when the home was listed in
being sold what was the sort of like
recent volume of transactions in that
market was it a liquid market or was a
quite a cold market we have square
features about the properties as well
and the thing we're trying to predict is
days on market
so I've label that Y so what's the first
thing I need data scientists would
probably try drop the nulls and fidelity
regression right well yeah that's what
we would try to but it doesn't work so
let's take a look at one way of sort of
analyzing a
performance on this task is to plot an
arrival curve which is to say like as a
function of the homes that have sold in
a given cohort so let's say we train a
model using data only available up to
you know the start of this year to the
start of 2018 and then we take all the
listings that go on the market in
January and we ask the question hey you
know make predictions for each of those
homes and come up with an estimate for
the average sort of days on market for
that cohort of homes that went on the
market in January so if you do that you
can plot as a function of the percent of
homes that actually close your
predictions of running average and the
beauty of this plot is you can sort of
plot the true value the actually
observed data as it comes in so what I'm
showing here in the the blue solid line
is the actual running average of homes
that are closing so as we observe more
and more homes closed the blue line of
actuals fills in and right now it looks
like you know our model is pretty
decently calibrated you know at 50
percent of homes observed you know the
running average and our models
prediction of the running average
you know roughly around two weeks of
time on the market for each listing but
as we observe more and more listings
close we see that our models performance
and predictions diverge from reality and
as the final sales come in we see that
our model is in fact quite bad it's
overly optimistic so to understand
what's going on and why this is
happening let's take a detour to World
War two
so here during the Second World War the
Navy came to a Columbia based think tank
called the statistical research group
with a problem too many other fighters
were being shot down overseas so they
had the idea that they wanted to armor
place additional armor on their planes
to help prevent them from being shot
down so they'd surveyed all the fighters
that returned home and they took a sort
of census of where
the damage on these planes was occurring
and they recommended armoring the place
that received the most damage on the
plane so Abraham Wald a statistician in
the group said no wait you've got it all
backwards
what you're observing are only the
planes that returned what you should
really be thinking about is the planes
that didn't return so if the damage is
uniformly distributed across the plane
and you should actually place the armor
on the spot of the planes with the least
amount of damage the engine and so
that's in fact what they did so our
housing data set has a similar kind of
bias by dropping those missing entries
those nulls for the homes that hadn't
quite yet sold and for those that like
we're still active on the market and
looking for a buyer we actually
introduced a survivor bias into our data
set the homes that sold our other planes
that returned and the homes that aren't
didn't sell are the planes that didn't
return so in this case when we have sort
of a partially observed outcome for the
variable we care about we call that
censoring so we know in this example
that 52 downtown Ave if it were to sell
it would it take at least 200 days so we
have a lower bound on the outcome we
care about and similarly for this home
90 outskirts lane that we're saying the
seller removed from the market so we
don't get to observe the actual outcome
at all we know it would have it would
have been at least 300 days before it
sold so which brings us to our sort of
first take away which is pay attention
to the negative space it's often very
easy and as data scientists were
conditioned to look at a data set and
extract insights from it but it's often
just as important to pay attention to
what's not there and what's missing but
often yeah so the first step is to think
about how the data was generated and
could there be any biases you know are
there missing data points are there is
there a survivor bias in your data so
so if you can't solve things with your
first attempt a good practice is of
course to try reframing the problem so
now we'll shift away from our initial
approach and try a different one with
hopefully a few less of the pitfalls
along the way another thing we can try
is taking our data set defining a
threshold call it a hundred days and and
saying hey any home that sold in under a
hundred days will treat that as a
positive example and any home that sat
on the market for more than a hundred
days if it's sold or if it's still
active or if it even delisted but at
least it survived a hundred days we'll
call that a negative example and then
we'll fit a binary classifier on this so
by switching from regression to
classification you know you can use all
the typical classification machinery you
know about and we get to include these
other sort of previous observations that
we weren't able to include in our
training data concretely it just means
it's a pre-processing step right you
shift your target variable from the
continuous sort of days on market to
this discrete you know closed within a
hundred days or did not so we get to use
the previous sales that we observed and
we'll label them one if they're you know
quite rapid sales and zero if they're
not and we also get to include the
previous listings that we dropped so
it's our second attempt but of course
doesn't work well I want to talk about
the pros and cons to set it up so the
first Pro is it's super easy to
implement right all it is is choosing a
threshold it's a pre-processing step and
then you switch your target variable
secondly it's really easy to interpret
the output it's you know you can treat
it you can look at the classifiers
confidence or the predicted probability
of each class and you can use this as a
proxy for risk a proxy for how long
things would take to sell and finally we
get to use that sensor data that I
mentioned we get to include the gray
delisting that sat on the market for
while as well as the home that had
enclosed in orange but that's had on the
market for a while what the cons so I
said it was easy to implement
you just had a threshold but it's
unclear how to do that you know it's you
have to be thoughtful about how that
threshold is said and in particular if
your results are sensitive to that
threshold and more importantly we're
also throwing away data which is sort of
like another theme of this talk we're
throwing away now the magnitude of the
sort of Thailand market so we're
treating homes that sold it within a
week and homes that sold in 99 days as
equivalent and that seems like a gross
assumption I said that output was easy
to interpret it's just like a risk score
but it's the wrong API it's not the
problem that we actually care about
we're interested in computing the the
exact time on market that's a compute
costs so it's unclear how you would roll
from those predicted probabilities of
basically quick sales and long sales to
like an expectation do you take the sort
of you know midpoint in each of these
that it's unclear how to do that in a
principled way the right API would be
more of a distribution over the outcomes
we care about and we could roll that
into a point estimate as the case might
be and finally I said we get to use all
the sensor data which is true we got to
use the the long surviving homes that we
previously had to exclude but it came at
a cost and I kind of glossed over it
if a home hasn't yet reached a hundred
days on the market then we can't
determine a label for it so we actually
are gonna throw away recent transactions
which as a business she's very
interested in understanding sort of the
near past or the recent past in the near
future this is quite problematic so are
we stuck with all these like sort of
hacky approaches and kind of band-aided
solutions of course not and that's what
we'll talk about next
this is where survival analysis comes in
it's kind of a funny thing that you
think about it's like we're in the real
estate business and why we're talking
about survival analysis the reason we
come upon this is I go with my very
simple problem-solving approach which is
anytime you get stuck try to look for
out of people solution and turns out
there are people who have thought about
problem very similar to this one before
so for example the people in life
insurance companies and medical
professionals they're very much
interesting similar problems kind of
like this so they ask questions such as
what is the life expectancy of a
population or what is the probability of
a person surviving the next decade or
given you already observed that this
person is 70 years old what's the chance
that this person will survive the next X
years and most importantly they always
have a deal with issues which we talked
about which is sensor data so if you do
a medical study you very rarely have the
opportunity to wait for many many
decades for seeing your entire
population to see the outcomes often
time you have to stop your study as some
years 10 or you're 15 and you have to
make some you have to understand what's
going on and so they always have to do
with issues of sensor data and so great
this is exactly kind of the problem
setting which want to come talk about
unfortunately we talk about this
particular topic it gets a little bit
morbid when you say oh it's this person
with died or not because survival
analysis fortunately for us though we're
gonna make our analogies and this
particular analogy def is actually happy
events of finding a buyer what do I mean
so instead of being interesting in
somebody's life expectancy were
interesting what is the expected based
on market for given listing or what's
the probability of a given listing
taking 10 more days to sell etc and so
Llosa we are finding very much a similar
problem that happy invert look upon by
parallel industries and there's a lot of
machineries and studies on this
particular problem and so to summarize a
little bit our previous to approach one
of them just kind of give you a number
which is a little bit wrong because it's
very optimistic
the other one give you a binary
probability which is interval but also a
little bit hard to use with survival
analysis this give us exactly what we
want which is a full probability
distribution of how long do we expect a
given home gonna stay on the market and
this is very important because not only
does this give us a much better view of
what's going on with a listing but it's
a business let's say we have a hundred
home in our inventory right now and we
say the expected days to market is sixty
days not all the homes gonna selling day
sixty like Tony Odom son was selling the
first week five of them is on the second
week etc and so by having a full
probability distribution that allows us
to plan our resources do a lot of
forecasting and stuff like that on top
of just knowing just the average so
let's pick us our first take away in
this particular problem with if you get
stuck often time look for similar
solutions and it's actually very useful
to look for parallels now it looks like
we define the right approach people have
thought about this quite a lot that what
are the problems and so we did run into
a few problems when we trying to
implement survival analysis in open door
well I'm gonna walk you through the
problems as well as our solution to it
and so problem number one it's actually
pretty hard to explain model so if you
look at survival analysis or also known
as has a model on Wikipedia you're gonna
see something like this which is if you
want to understand some of the very
basic concepts of survival functions or
the hazard rate basically any calculus
so explain well so you can say okay
what's what's the problem we'll let the
data science take care of this problem
which is give you a prediction
unfortunately if you work in a business
where this is one of the core model of
your business
you cannot really just have a model that
people cannot gain an intuition a point
if it's just a black box and so if we
can't explain this model we can't really
use it to help people make decisions and
the hurdle number two which is also a
very common problem when you start using
a slightly more complex model in
production which is it's hard to scale
with the to order you find there's a lot
of our package out there that help you
do a lot of sophisticated work on that
but there's very much limited options
with production-ready languages and also
even with some of the packages you tried
out with the tiny Davis
and it works great and you mean the big
one and suddenly all kind of edge cases
coming and it's a little bit hard to use
and the last problem we run into you
kind of related to the previous one it's
a little bit hard to use some extended
model with some of the way that we want
to use a model so with off-the-shelf
solutions you very much limited to you
know two options proportional or
additive has a model and there's not
very flexible way to specify some of the
features for one one of them you can use
continuous feature which is problematic
we also want to implement something
called time variant feature which I'll
talk a little bit later so it doesn't
really let us to put the full use of
full flexibility of the way we want to
model a problem and so in the very
beginning when with a completely
different approach its soon specifying
our house model and our survival model
using a very rich model specification
and using Monte Carlo techniques to
solve it that's that's great I let us
specify the model exactly the way we
want unfortunately it takes hour to
train on a tiny data set and it's really
hard to maintain because of that so yeah
we're running to all the problems what
do we do
it's one of the themes are you probably
see in this talk is if you can't solve
the problem try to reformulate it and
that's exactly what we're going to do
right now so instead of telling you all
about the traditional concepts in hazard
model and survival analysis so I'm gonna
skip all those you know people I'm all
over people's name on it and how you a
reformulation that our promise is be
easy to scale to large data sets that's
potentially more concretely tied to
real-life numbers and also it's
equivalent to the survival analysis and
allows for a flexible model extensions
so how do I do that
so hold on to your seat belt we're gonna
change your target again remember this
particular thing we talked about so 423
Main Street has data I take 30 date
itself so instead of using this
particular data row we're going to turn
this to a different data set for each
day the homes on the market so in this
case 30 days we're gonna make one row
out of that so we turn one row into 30
rows here
and the target variable we talked about
is whether the home was sold that they
after and so in this case the home said
our marketing for 29 days without
selling and then we was sold on the last
day and so we have 29 negative examples
and one positive examples what about all
the sensor things that we care about in
every beginning the home that did not
sell or a home that was taken off the
market very much the same idea
for example fountain Avenue that was
still sitting on market after 200 days
how do I do this well who make 200 row
out of this and since this home never
sold our target variable would be on
zero for this run one row so to quickly
summarize we change our fundamental
units of data we started with individual
listings or individual homes but now we
actually go into a different space which
is for each stay the listings on a
market that is our units of data one
finger notes is all we're using all
listing datas we're not dropping
anything whether the home is closed so
active or taken off the market we still
use it every day the home is on the
market is the data point for us so what
does the give us soon sigh we're
changing a problem to a completely
different one well for one we're back to
a binary classification again which is
great because a sauce you can have a
classifier that minimize lot loss and
you have calibrated probability pick
your favorite off-the-shelf out
algorithms and just go run with it so
the funny thing is we made our data sets
bigger because now one returning to
multiple ones but I actually made a
problem much more scalable because like
binary classification problem is well
studied and like there's many many
off-the-shelf solution to scale it to
large data sets and so we self our
scalability problem which is great when
you see how problem in term ability so
now we're talking about a binary
prediction of probability of a listing
closing in the next day which is
basically has array if you think about
survival analysis but that is still not
very interpretive what does I even mean
turns out this is actually something we
can use in a very business oriented
context turns out this prediction Maps
directly into a concept called clearance
rates or housing clearance rate what
does that mean so if we start with 100
home on the market today so that's
inventory how many of them were closed
before the end of the day or before the
end of the month or year and so that's
very high to a concept that people think
about on a day to day basis
how quickly does the inventory turnover
and that the great thing is this map
directly into our model output which
means we kind of solve our
interpretation problem which is a model
output tied directly into real-world
numbers that people understand we don't
we don't have to using calculus to
explain the concepts of course we didn't
completely explain the problem here we
still have to predict the data market or
the home which is a problem we
originally set out to self fortunately
for us the prediction which I'm gonna
call it has a way for sure right now
it's a building block for everything we
want to know about this particular
listing or a cohort of listings all you
need to add is regular walls of
probability so let me give you an
example this is a thing with China
prediction on very very beginning how
long would this home stay on the market
what's expecting based on market
how does this work is remember we turn a
given listing to multiple rows which
means we'll have multiple predictions
were given listing and so for one
listing will have the prediction for
each of the days and we have h1 h2 h3
etc to get the expected day star market
we use a lot of probability right so
expected value of anything it's all a
possible value of that particular thing
multiplied by probability and you sum it
up so same deal you kind of model it's
kind of expanded out how this works the
first term here for example says when
the the value we're talking about is
days our market you could have one and
the probability of that happening is
just our first prediction and a second
term here very similar the value we're
talking about is days of market equal to
two and the probability of that
happening is first we need to not sound
a home on day one and then multiply it
by the probability of the home selling
on day two so just lots of Paula bility
and there you go we get our prediction
that we look for just by using lots of
probability and our set of predictions
so one takeaway here is we change our
model from a fairly complex technique of
survival analysis into just binary
classification and so potentially if you
think about a problem a different way
complex modeling techniques which you
may want to use that's not always near
complex implementation and that's good
news because that allows us to scale our
modeling techniques to bigger data sets
and cetera now you might think that's a
little bit magical how does that how
does survivor analysis kind of map to a
binary classification in this completely
different formulation so I want to give
you a taste of how this might work so
this is not a rigorous proof Norris is
complete just a sense of how this might
work so for this work let's look a lot
loss in a binary classification so
looking up on any text book looks
something like this
so is sum over loss for each of your
data and then you sum this out just
reminder since we're only talking about
binary classification here only one term
contributes here sorry and then go back
to our problem which is survival
analysis want to maximize our models
likelihood how does this work very
similar formulation as everything else
once you know the likelihood of our
model of our data given that we have a
model and want to maximize that and so
you write out the terms here just like
with it before basically lots of
probabilities and then we take the log
of both side and spoiler alerts it looks
very much like a lot loss that we
started with
so that's just one rough sign of why
this particular formulation map back to
our one way to think about a problem
which is survival analysis
so yeah I've shown you a reformulation
that skeletal large data sets well that
ties to real life numbers and it's more
or less equivalent to survival analysis
and so the next part I want to show you
what I mean by flexible model extensions
on top of this proof formulation so the
first thing I want to mention is what we
call time varying features what do you
mean by time varying well so a listing
is going to set on market from anywhere
from a few days to a few years and a lot
of change a lot of things can change
during that time so one of the important
thing is the listening could change
price if a home doesn't sell a person
could be tempted to draw price and to
see if that sells better and so one
question Wanda asked is the surprise
change affects how quickly the home sell
and that's one example of a time-varying
feature like the feature that changed
for our list of the listings lifetime
it's how do you do that well it's
actually not very easy to implement in a
lot of off-the-shelf solutions you end
up doing very much a data transformation
that we end up already did so how do we
do that you notice in our new
formulation well it's actually really
simple all you do just add a new feature
to your model nothing changed because
we're already looking at listening from
a granularity of per day and so if the
listing have a time-varying features you
just have to plug that feature in for
that particular day and so this allows
very easily incorporate features that
change over time over the listings
lifetime another thing we want to do is
some sort of time series analysis what
do I mean by time series well
unfortunately housing data and while
real life in general it's not really a
stationary here's one example there's a
crisis last decade where home prices go
way up and then go away back down again
and you see the same thing with her with
liquidity so the home sat on market for
a very long time when the crisis
happened and the other example of this
is this is how fast the home is currying
of the market and you see that on a
weekly basis so we see that every year
there's such an event called Christmas
and during Christmas time people don't
really buy and sell houses so you see a
very pronounced seasonality in a trend
we talking about and so for us as a
business understand liquidity and we
need to understand the various trend
whether it's long term or seasonal trend
and so that's what I mean by time series
analysis now how do we do that in the
framework of survival models well it's
actually pretty tricky to implement the
reason is often time we take a listing
centric view which each row is a listing
and the reason why that doesn't work
well is if the listing lasts on the
market for one year that seasonality
trends gonna get blended out
you're gonna you're not going to be able
to model those very well and so we
really want to do is stretch for like a
time-based view unfortunately we already
have that because we will formulate our
problem in terms of a segmenting time
per for each listings and so one way you
can do this you train a series of model
using a snapshot listings at a given
time so what do I mean so here is
in x-axis the time and so we see their
Home Instead get listed at different
times and then close off the market
different time so by talking about
snapshot we can say only look at listing
during this time while there are four
listings on a market here and one of
them closed you can train a model only
using those data during that time and
then we can keep training more models in
very similar ways so in a sense you get
a time series of models and then once
you have that actually you want to use
one of your favorite time series and you
can have to interpretate the predictions
so if you want to do seasonal analysis
on time great do whatever you want to do
so then we actually reduce our problem
down to a different set of problem again
which is like whatever proper tool you
can use in time series analysis so one
quick takeaway here is if your complex
model you want to solve a complex model
you can divide and conquer so find an
intermediate step in this case we
transform our problem to a different
data sets and once we get there where
you can actually use that to potentially
extend them all doing very different
ways that that's very useful but beside
the fact that you can get through your
original final go so I talked about
survival analysis and in real estate but
really it's it's invite widely
applicable technique and use in other
places so here are some examples one
thing you might care about is how
quickly the that's user turnout of a
given service often time that was
thought as a binary prediction problem
that's a user turn or not but it's
actually really just like a time to
events right you want to know not only
whether user turned we also know when
they do that and also how long what
probability would they do it if you care
about lifetime value you need a full
probability distribution as well you
also might care about this in terms of
loan defaults because even even though
it sometimes people think about loan
default as a binary classification
problem did the loan default or not it's
very different if your borrower defaults
early on you know long well you lose
more money versus much later on where
you lose less money you can also talk
about actual survival analysis like for
example when this hard drive died so
anytime you have a time to event
prediction it's potentially useful tool
kit
that you can use so you know ask a
doctor if the survival analysis is right
for you well here's a few attributes
potentially want to consider when you
think about whether you want to use of
ever analysis because it's a potentially
more complex modeling techniques well
first of all you need some model that
something you want a model which is
either time three events or even just
binary classification sensor data
usually a quick crew for you to say if I
want to think about those in a
principled way survive analysis is a
good way to use if you value full
problem with these two probability
distribution survivor analysis gives you
that and if you think about time as a
confounding factor so if you think about
cohorts or mixture over time and cetera
so if everyone else is also a great way
to think about that problem in a
principled way and I hope I show you
that if you decide a survival analysis
useful to you there is a easy way to use
it without the full machinery of you
know going through our package etc so
we're showing you a formulation that is
very easy to follow it's easily scalable
to a large data set it's concretely it's
high to reelect number potentially and
definitely allows you to model various
things on top of your particular problem
and all you need to do is transform the
dataset into a different shape and then
run a binary classifier on top of that
so with that thanks for coming coming to
this talk this work is done we
collaborate in a lot of people open door
unfortunately we all have a face color
change by this particular volunteer we
love emojis and we'll also love working
on complex problems and this is just one
of the problems that we worked on at
open door if you have any questions feel
free to email us
[Applause]
or talk about it now
with different houses costing different
amounts Wow
why not try two-dollar eyes this in some
way for example having the cost to keep
the house on open doors books on a per
day basis as instead of the zeros in
lots of rows that you made and then the
dollars created from the sale instead of
the one yeah sure we definitely think
about things in terms of dollar amounts
but you do want to break down a problem
in a way that you can understand so for
example a home causes different amount
of money depends on where like later on
we might have higher financing costs and
depends on seasonality we might have a
different kind of costs so we want to
know kind of decompose the problem in
two parts so if I only put costing it
we've kind of couple everything
including like maybe in the summer we'll
need to clean the pool more versus in
winter we need a shop with us no and
like that inflammation is a little bit
too complex to put in one single model
if you can break it out that's much
better does that kind of answer your
question yeah I guess I would add on to
what sumo is saying which is like you
know that quantity itself is also
something that is often reported as a
you know baseline business metric so
it's not like often like to her point
about being tied to a business metric
like one of the metrics you really do
track it is sort of the inventory
turnover rate it's nice that that
yes and there might be something I'm
under not understanding about the
reformulation but how do you deal with
houses that are like on the market for a
long time that means you have a lot more
rows than the other houses so how do you
deal with the kind of that having a
larger weight in your model
that's a great question when we went to
started with this formulation we thought
maybe the weight we should do a weighted
lot loss instead and like longer Dom
home longer the home that sit on the
market for longer should be weighted
less but actually if you go back to the
the non rigorous proof I have for why
this two formulation is similar you
actually see that you don't want to
underweight it basically if you're
underway that you end up under waiting a
long time the long sorry I keep saying
that but that means they to market and
if the homes safe a long time you
actually don't want to weight it lest
you can't have to go through the math a
little bit to see why that's the case I
don't think I have a great and intuitive
explanation of that
excellent presentation question about
time to event so in the beginning you
mentioned to sort of motivate the
presentation that you could use this for
sports or other things so I understand
the use of time to event in the housing
situation because while there is some
seasonality the market where the house
is is somewhat fixed so the competition
so that those things are more or less
constant even though they can change a
little bit but in a sporting situation
to use a very mundane example if you're
trying to figure out like how long it is
before your team scores as you mentioned
if they if you're trying to plot that
between matches let's say and so who
you're playing changes or things like
that have you guys thought at all about
how time to event is useful as those
kinds of environmental factors change
rather abruptly yeah I think that's a
great question so I think with this
formulation it's quite general in the
sense that like you can include all this
kind of side information about what two
teams are competing to help control for
those kind of changes that you're
talking about yeah does that
yeah I was curious in the Hazzard
modelling you doing it has the process
of like opened or finding product market
fit and as you're expanding like has
opened or itself introduced signal into
your hazard model that you have to
correct for yeah definitely
so one of the great thing that this
particular formulation let's do is we
can introduce like if we change our
business policy at a given dates that
become a feature in our model in a very
natural way like that feature could be a
binary picture of like zero until that
day and then one off after that day and
so it's actually very natural to
incorporate any business related change
you can induce in a model
maybe I didn't get it at the
presentation but there's a house let's
just see this did or just you know
didn't never get sold on the markets how
you model that into your into your model
yeah yeah and so in in in the to sort of
a like classification scenarios it sort
of depends on how long the delisting is
on the market for but in in this sort of
general form that we talked about where
we had a a sort of exploded version of
our data set for each listing you know
an example based on sort of the listing
de combinations those just become
negative examples so you don't actually
get to observe for like a home veterans
of delisting that that event so we just
say hey this is you know contributing
some weight to the the fact that homes
what like it will not actually close but
it's not necessarily an explicit like
hey this week this home delisted we
don't we don't use that
[Music]